le nouveau conseil municipal prendra ses
fonctions ce samedi 17 juin à 9h à la
salle Francis poulinck quels seront les
premières mesures annoncées on en parle
avec notre invités qui vient d'être élu
bonjour Brice ravier bonjour votre liste
donc est arrivé en tête de l'élection
municipale d'Amboise ce weekend vous
avez remporté 62% des suffrages c'est un
score important il y a quand même que
44% de participation de participation
donc on peut dire plus d'un électeur sur
deux ne s'est pas déplacé qu'est-ce
comment vous allez aller chercher ses
amboisins que vous n'avez pas convaincu
je pense déjà que c'est on peut voir le
verre à moitié plein et le verre à
moitié vide mais là je le vois à moitié
plein c'est près de la moitié des
omboisins qui se sont déplacés c'est
vrai que c'est pas on préférait 80% mais
c'est une réalité où nous sommes sur une
élections intermédiaires qui n'a pas un
écho médiatique national et le fait que
les amboisiennes les amboisiens soient
déplacés plus grand nombre qu'en 2020
des notes aussi de leur intérêt pour
cette élection le score et lui
effectivement important et nous donne
aussi la force d'avancer alors vous
l'avez dit plusieurs fois déjà la
première chose que vous ferez c'est un
audit financier oui financier de
fonctionnement c'est l'objectif est de
voir vraiment les marges de manœuvre
qu'on peut avoir et d'adapter après en
fonction de notre projet mais oui je
veux vraiment faire cette audit quelque
chose de très précis qui nous permettra
d'avoir au moins une vision plus claire
de ce que sont les finances de la ville
et puis également de du fonctionnement
la ville alors justement les finances
sont incertaines et vous n'avez que
trois ans contrairement aussi sa rituel
200 points dans votre programme est-ce
que comment vous allez faire pour
pouvoir tout mettre en place dans les
temps et avec le financement
j'ai un gros projet chez une équipe
ultra compétente très solidaire qui a
vraiment envie d'avancer et puis j'ai
aussi la faiblesse de penser que les
services de la ville même s'ils ont été
assez malmenés ces derniers temps sont
particulièrement compétents et je l'ai
dit durant l'ensemble de la campagne et
je continuerai de le dire je fais
confiance aux agents de la ville
d'Amboise et je sais que nous allons
réussir ce beau projet parce que notre
ville le vaut bien
on peut parler équipement sportif il y a
des manques à Amboise
quels sont vos priorités et pour quand
est-ce que déjà il y a quelque chose qui
est entrevue
de fonctionnement il y a effectivement
un audit sur les équipements je sais
qu'il y a une structure le gymnase
guiner qui est qui a été
particulièrement impacté et qui a un
défaut d'entretien et notamment la
structure d'escalade qui n'est plus
fonctionnelle et le panneau un panneau
de basket donc le club de basket
fonctionne sur un Mitterrand donc là
tout de suite nous devons nous
concentrer sur
quelle est la cause comment réparer et
que faire et puis après j'ai commencé
déjà à prendre contact et je travaille
avec et la ville de Posay et le maire de
Pocé-sur-Cisse Claude courgeot ainsi que
le club de basket pour voir comment sur
le championnat régional puisque l'équipe
d'Amboise est inscrite au championnat
régional comment on va pouvoir continuer
les matchs le week-end à bossé sur 6
la maison de santé c'est aussi un point
phare de votre programme ou devrait-elle
voir le jour finalement et quand c'est
pas que la maison de santé parce que
c'est l'outil la maison de santé c'est
l'attractivité le travail à faire avec
l'ensemble de la communauté médicale et
le travail à faire aussi avec l'ensemble
des partenaires donc
Corinne Simoneau le docteur Corinne
Simoneau et Johnny verquille qui sera le
futur adjoint au sport et à la santé et
quand une Simoneau quand une délégation
particulière pour travailler sur cette
attractabilité du corps médical et
l'ensemble de l'offre de soins sur
Amboise si mais a commencé de s'y mettre
déjà dès aujourd'hui et c'est vraiment
un gros travail qu'on a fournir l'outil
viendra derrière en même temps on peut
encore de date définie c'est pas une
date même une pierre mais voilà il y a
du foncier et il y a la possibilité de
le faire sur Amboise donc travaillons
ensemble de concert justement en parlant
de fonciers je j'en ai parlé un peu
immobilier le les prix grimpe à Amboise
notamment à cause des Airbnb qui
fleurissent un peu partout dans la
commune ce qui a quelque chose que vous
allez faire à ce propos alors je sais
pas si c'est que la photo meublée
tourisme mais effectivement les prix
sont quand même assez élevés sur en
Boisse c'est aussi un système d'offre et
de la demande vous avez envie une très
belle ville pour lequel les biens sont
plutôt rares et lorsque c'est rare c'est
cher donc ça c'est aussi un une vision
de fonctionnement par contre nous notre
not way c'est vraiment de retravailler
sur du foncier alors comme la loi nous
l'oblige zéro artificialisation un
foncier qui soit un peu dynamique avec
des dents creuses mais quelque chose
avec un l'environnement 2 avec les
lotisseurs peut-être travailler avec
d'autres lotisseurs et être plus malin
et et inclure le bien vivre des échos
quartiers avoir une vision peut-être
différente de ce qui s'est passé
dans le passé et d'avoir peut-être une
logique moins minérale et plus plus
enclins avec le bien vivre à Amboise
et enfin des colis de produits
alimentaires ont été détournés au sein
du CCAS depuis c'est la Croix-Rouge qui
a pris le relais pour la distribution et
le maire Thierry Boutard comptait porter
plainte est-ce que vous vous allez
poursuivre cette action en justice alors
je ne connais ni le fond ni la forme du
dossier donc là ce sont des dossiers que
je veux avoir à traiter très rapidement
et une fois que j'en connais très un peu
plus la cause le fonctionnement ce qui
en est ce qui a été réellement fait et
bien je prendrai des décisions qu'il
faut prendre ça c'est sûr
merci